all right ohio republican senator rob
portman doesn't need any reminding about
the severity of things at the border
with or without title 42 going away uh
he has had meetings with uh the homeland
security secretary majorcas he was kind
enough to join us today uh rob portman
very good to see you senator hey dale
um this title 42 issue i guess that will
be debated at a hearing held until that
hearing uh
police may 13th this takes effect may
23rd if nothing changes that is removing
title 42 but you're saying this goes way
beyond whether that stays or goes right
yes first title 42 is now in court
there's a louisiana district court that
has said the administration cannot end
it now but they haven't given a date as
to when it could be ended the
administration said just a couple hours
ago that they're going to go along with
the court on this so we don't know what
the date is yet but the bottom line is
42 is a public health order in other
words let's do with covet at some point
it's going to go away we hope you know
covet goes away and so we need a a
solution that's much deeper than that i
mean the problem is that although about
half the people are being sent back
under title 42 the other half are being
led into our country and and that's
roughly a million people last year it
looks like this year we're on track to
have about two million people
people who come to the border unlawfully
apply for asylum are allowed to go in
spend somewhere between six and eight
years waiting for their court case by
that time embedded in the community very
few are ever sent home in fact during
the first eight months of the uh of the
biden administration the first eight
months there were only 26 000 people
sent back by expedited removal
and about 800 000 people had come in
unlawfully so that's the problem we've
got to solve we've become a magnet for
people from all over the world because
they know they can come to our border
claim asylum and walk in
do you get a sense when you ran on this
phone call with homeland security
secretary marcus uh of any of his
private doubts uh about where things
stand and his concern um that were
leaked out
did he relay any of that that this is
now getting
out of control to your point
well listen i'm not going to talk about
what he said in that call but i'll talk
about what he said publicly which is
consistent with what he said in the call
which is he thinks the system is broken
and it clearly is nobody can look at
this system and say it's working
my own view for what it's worth now is
we should have legal immigration and
even increase that with regard to the
skills we need in this country
so open the front door a little more but
let's close the back door it's not only
about illegal immigration it's about the
drug issue because as you know the most
dangerous of the drugs particularly the
synthetic opioid called fentanyl is now
coming in through our southern border
dramatic increases in those numbers
along with the dramatic increases in
immigration and that's what's affecting
every state including mine with record
numbers of overdose deaths and most of
them are occurring because of fentanyl
so it's all related
and
there's an obvious solution here which
is let's on a bipartisan basis fix this
problem so our immigration system works
the way it was intended senator well i
have you here and i know you're a
senator uh but looking at the comments
of kevin mccarthy and that he might have
misrepresented himself others say he
lied about uh not recommending
that donald trump should should resign
in the face of the january 6 attack on
the hill uh
when in fact an audio tape reveals that
that was a concern it is and he was
going to present that to the president
do you think uh that this is much to do
about nothing that uh you know kevin
mccarthy should not be the republican
leader in the house or if the
republicans take the house the next
speaker
well i i think it's much to do about
stuff that i have nothing to do with
in other words the house republicans are
going to make that decision and they
will also i think judge kevin mccarthy
on everything he has done to try to
achieve the house republican majority
which i think he's uh
you know online to achieve so i think
that will be considered also the emotion
of the time you know january 6 was a
very difficult time for for all of us up
here so look i i i that's a decision the
house republicans are going to make
i i do think they're likely to get the
majority and if you look at the numbers
today
it's partly because of this border issue
partly because of inflation but the
american people are looking for a change
they're looking for
more consistency in terms of how we deal
with things like the border how we deal
with uh things like stimulus spending
that got out of control and contributed
in a big way to this inflation and
people get that so i think the house
republicans are likely to get the
majority here in the senate you know
it's a little less certain but uh right
now it almost looks like the you know
politically it's going to be good year
for republicans so real quickly i mean
you mentioned the the the angst around
the reaction that the folks like
yourself and others had mitch o'connell
at the time of the january sixth
uprising uh but it then dissipated very
very quickly and it seems like very few
were willing to take on donald trump or
or to rehash that do you think that's
best now the way things are
well i don't know i mean i i issued a
report along with uh senator blunt from
the rules committee i'm on the home i'm
ranking on the homeland security
committee the top republican and then we
had our two chairs uh amy klobuchar and
gary peters and it's a very
straightforward report and it just talks
about the lapses here what happened how
it happened
um you know i i think
that is good to have those reports out
there to be looked at so that we can
avoid the future january 6. got it
senator thank you very much rob portman
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now